hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast advancing biomedical
science live cell imaging a vesicle
trafficking using perfectly balanced
super resolution dragonfly microscopy
I'm Christie jollof lab rats and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is brought to
you by laberd's and sponsored by and/or
for more information on our sponsor
please visit and/or calm
let's get started I would like to remind
everyone that today's event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation use that ask a question box
to let us know you're experiencing a
problem
today's webinar is educational in this
offers free continuing education credits
at the end of the presentation please
click on the continuing education
credits tab and follow the process to
obtain your credit
I'd now like to introduce our first
presenter dr. Kazuaki yoga staff
researcher at the department of
physiology
Kanazawa University Graduate School of
Medical Science in Japan also joining us
as Meredith price product and business
manager at Amara and dr. Claudia Flor
endo product specialists life sciences
at and/or for complete biographies on
our speakers please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen
dr. Yoshioka you may now begin your
presentation
so thank you for giving me a wonderful
opportunity to make this way we limit
William now so I would like to introduce
recent my amazing data by and/or Drago
Frye so let me have some introduction
first so the membrane trafficking
including endocytosis and exercising
pathways are recently well studied
using conventional point scanning
confocal microscopy we had discarded
imaging the fast-moving into syrup
vegetables such like preferring coated
vesicles and songs and rhizomes with
side of the less than a few hundred
nanometers
so this time-lapse moving will be
opening some trafficking has been taken
by Yokogawa CSU best provoke a
microscope almost ten years ago
so looks not so bad however it's still
not enough so from now I will show you a
recent imaging data using under
drama-free microscope so drama fly has
very nice future you know there are
mainly for laser marriage kara high
speed high resolution and longer time
period
so before that the actual data I just
want to show you some background in es3
class family study
so forth NuStar 3-kinase PSEG family has
three classes one two three plus one
consists of four members he want an
alpha P 110 beta Delta and gamma on the
other hand there are three crust to life
form
it's our for beta that Damo
in addition to the single class we will
be 34 so we have been focusing wrong
with logical role of trust through P SDK
in endocytosis because su conserva has
clustering binding domain in n-terminal
region so class 1 PS really produce e
I three four five III it's called III at
plasma membrane by receptor tyrosine
kinase or people reporting a percept
activation so it activates a KP to
regulate wide variety of cell function
proliferation losses migration and so on
and graph 3 p SE k bt 34 is now famous
because with the 34 induces or fatty by
starvation so our group discovered that
trusted baek produce pi/3 p or EI 342 on
on the plasma membrane
or clustering dependent and psychosis
now we understand grass - paca has very
potent function the membrane trafficking
control to regulate many cellular
function so we made no catalyst then we
found that expectedly she prefer global
kill mice cause ambling clonality
this photo is for mount anti city
certain strain this ec marker of e 11.5
embryo so you can see the nicely you
know blood vessel formation in wild-type
but in knockout mice the vascular defect
was found to be a defect in vascular
formation such a non redundant role of
acids alpha
so this movie showing the GFP and m5
domain live imaging so this is pi/3 is a
sick frog so now you can see the dynamic
movement of RA and soul so this indicate
that we was impressed in with this movie
shitara knock themselves showed severe
defects of endosomal trafficking in
knockdown cells
then I checked next I will check the
involvement of sheets alpha in receptor
endocytosis
this slide shows you know straining of
anti possibly EGF receptor 2 and E a 1
this is early endosome marker so now you
can see the early endosome in red color
without relief stimulation in both cells
the belief is very important critical
growth factor for in details function so
after we live stimulation 2 minutes you
can see nicely activation will be our 2
receptor in both cells
thirty minutes
the
we also believe our two signals were
detected in AE a one a positive early
endosome in control cells but not in C
Java knockdown cells to indicate that
shit'll for depletion impairs the
endocytosis of activate believe our two
receptor
and to monitor the precise sub-zero
localization ESET she'd our fur we
utilize new tools and audre la vie this
video showing sub screen
super-resolution imaging all single
driver
double traffic with if it's alpha and mr
sztyc referring
so from magnified view here
can clearly see six alpha positive than
a vesicle formation that were mostly
record override with rfp clattering in
only short time build the dis panel
shows failure images of the recruitment
of GFP sheet alpha
do
the classroom
the stream I'm sorry
you can see clearly see it's a positive
learning basic formation co-localize
with Russell information but cheater for
recruitment is little delay
so let me summarize briefly what we have
found
she survived localized mainly to
crackling coating feet were cluttering
Katya Tabasco which produce the led to a
plasma membrane or ps3 beyond aliens own
to facilitate in psychosis so we found
that sheet alpha is essential for class
remediate endocytosis of regional food
and also Asante one septa mrs. G protein
couple septa and subject security and so
much small G protein Joey at one
occupation on our engines to control and
audiences so in addition we also
published that the serine threonine
kinase that received a tgf-beta receptor
85
also depends on sheets alpha so I
skipped some data then as our next
challenge in PSE study the question is
what difference between sheets are for
City bed ice holes so here I will show
you in bitter stat using dragonfly
microscope
here is a semantic structures free ice
forms of grass to Keisuke
Siddhartha has pristine binding domain
in internal rhythm but sheet alpha does
not instead has unique domain
it's called protein rich region again
come in timeless then we try to
emphasize the possibility that it's
alpha and Sheeta beta has distinct
mechanisms to control in psychosis to
study this point we utilize parasitosis
model final hypothesis one of the
endocytic processes teres engulf
accessory fruit and solute by mainly to
root a class remediated were no mediated
so first we examine the involvement of
PSE as homes in parasitosis using FITC
dextra uptake assay so each specific SR
in a knockdown efficiently knockdown
they are respective proteins
so no clavo knockdown of each each [ __ ]
alpha watch it so beta is Miss country
induced reduced the fitc disruptive
compared with scramble control srna the
interestingly Nakhla of class one even
alpha well with the 34 did not
and again and also we did double knock
down opposite enforce it's a beta so
interestingly double knock down so no
longer father in official suggesting
that both alpha beta are acting are on
the same pathway open psychosis
then I try to examine the top favorite
localization gfp-tagged shits larvae and
amateur little Shih Tzu beta in sensors
by and order alpha G fishy surfer was
distributed as panic button widely suits
ours
I'm a cherished Zubaydah was seeing as
restricted I mean we perinuclear after
pattern and also find found in the
plasma membrane so interesting by using
super resolution half screen mode
Jeff digital hub seeds are for what
found in art a patent is green Cara
whereas cherish its beta was found in
mesh life fracture so only a few
overarching opposites alpha and beta was
of that maybe this is a kind of class
link or deep pit
the previous study already showed that
both [ __ ] for unsheathed beta in cell
migration and actin polymerization we
confirmed that localization of digits
alpha and cherished su beta with acting
from it using following staining in
fixed cells so amateur sheets alpha but
not its alpha was highly localized with
F H gene structures including membrane
ruffling and acting patches in the self
Avery
so this movie is live cell imaging of
GST C to beta and a faction probe called
reflux probe in endothelial cells using
by dragonflies a story mode to magnify
the view here
join the dynamic active structural
remember and referring and those are
referring so you can see action film
information with were Caracas with DC to
beta positive baseball
so we next study the Electra build extra
optics in cells that expressed Arctic
referring and acting probe in green so
we found that some
a portion of this signal is showing
purple
the excess signal associated with
crafting and affecting this evidence
indicates that anisotropy and the best
Google clustering coated and FRG
associate
then we studied the role of [ __ ] cell
phone it's better in the formation and
that kid on the base course associate
efficacy active patches so knock down
his sheets are for worship to better
substantially inhibited the extra uptake
here
Noctowl double is a sheet alpha beta
also inhibited the association of a
faction crafting and also association of
the extra and F acting in only she to
beta
so this panel is magnified view
kuroh correlation between oxygen patches
and classy were reduced in its better
the heated cells
so the correlation between dexter and
absent parties was also released in
situated appeasers so again these
finding indicates that seatbelt is
required for the formation of rustling
quality or clustering code basic
associate acting parties
next question with how she Tibet illegal
- grasping codpiece and facilities
activity formation at classical
structure so what we found is that
intersecting one is March functional
scaffold protein which was originally
found to be localized in the crafting
code it so intersection one can bind to
shih-tzu beta through the interaction
between sh three regions of the section
one and protein division of ships beta
under recent study was also showed that
intersection one recruits Escobar
protein in the classic OTP
we stimulate action-packed formations
salute and wasps and wasp is involved in
action polymerization step this step is
dependent on luck and cdc42
summarize this last part PSEG shatrova
and Shih Tzu beta are necessary for
Christina deep parasitosis PSEG turf is
localized to clustering 42 feet and base
course whereas its beta is mainly
localized to clustering audit and
Vascular associate a packaging
so it's a beta facility the formation of
acting patches at wrestling coach
structure
intersection is the cruelty are required
for the formation Krasny associate at
extreme parties and the local
relationships Baker at active parties
besides city beta sheets are far also
regulate clustering body information by
different mechanisms the sheath larvae
to produce ef3 for people at
cross-linked OTP and regulate sorting
nexin 9 or up to 3 to regulate acting
organization contraction and this mob CC
buoyed by dynamic
so we conclude that she performs its
better differentially regulated in MIDI
in cytosis
so this is rough right I want to
summarize my talk
so we fully realized that craft to the
case seems to be responsible to produce
es3 for people and pspp
in in the endocytic vesicles and
subsequently to regulate the classroom
indeed in psychosis now we believe that
trust to PSV kala great not only defect
in psychosis and also let's for the
signals on the in songs hold in the soma
signaling
so now we now understand that three
classes of PS DK family can be
distinguished by their distance arrow
functions
brass one PSV carry received immediate
engineering does membrane trust to
regulate in psychosis and also no soma
signaling +3 bt 34 regulate or fadi in
the Ottawa so
so thank you very much for the attention
that's all
hi everyone my name is Meredith price
and today I'm going to talk to you about
amorous and how you can use it for
interest intracellular dynamics and the
study of those in the analysis maras is
a 3-d and 4-d visualization and analysis
software for microscopy images
and with in Amar's you're able to do a
number of different types of analysis
and visualize your data thoughts whether
they're smaller comfortable data
thoughts or large like light sheet
images and specifically for
intracellular dynamics you can study
vesicles and organelles their
interactions with each other or
cytoskeletal and Giglio components and
how they're moving over time within your
images and you're also able to even
study things like mRNAs and specifically
looking at at them like like the liang
zhang jian paper that was just recently
published within molecular cell where
they used a cooper system system to look
at RNAs within living cells and so you
can see that down that an image from
that paper in this slide and so there's
a variety of different types of
questions you can ask and amuse amorous
and its analysis specifically it's
tracking analysis to better understand
these dynamics that are happening within
yourself
specifically the types of things Amar's
can report for you give you are not only
to identify each spot that you might be
in your imagine and in this case we're
looking at the ends of microtubules
within a spindle from the paper from
Yamashita but you're also able to get
that position over time a Mars will
calculate the speed give you other
motility measurements
you can also get track weeks its
duration the total displacement that you
see per track again throughout your
movie
and even more importantly you can start
to understand how these objects that
you're tracking whether they are or
something like the tip of the
microtubule or a vesicle or organelles
how they are interacting with other
objects in your images and so there's
been work done using Amara Square groups
are looking at different types of
organelles and how they are interacting
interacting with one another so are they
touching one another are they very close
to one another and how long do they
maintain that that connection or that
interaction and so one thing I do want
to point out is that for all of the all
of these types of results and the work
that you do within a warrant you do need
to make sure that you're paying
attention to the constraint that you
have on your imaging so you have spatial
and temporal resolution constraints
while you're doing live still image in
many of us know that and I want to
mention that during your imaging if if
you have constraints on spatial or
temporal resolutions this can affect
your analysis and so it's something to
keep in mind as you're going into any
analysis software not just a Mars but
others as well that having the best
spatial resolution so that you can
detect the objects that you're actually
that you're actually wanting to analyze
as well as making sure that you have
high temporal resolution so that you're
tracking is as accurate as possible
it is incredibly important so optimizing
your imaging for those two reasons it is
important of course
now how do we get to that end point I
gave you a number of different examples
of the measurements that are possible
with NMR s from the time-lapse images
that you're acquiring but how do we get
there and so the first the first thing
that you would want to do is to go and
identify or segment all of the objects
through time then you're able to go in
and perform tracking and then finally
once you have this track you can go you
can go into a Mars and do different
types of analysis of those tracks as
well as various types of recording that
are available and so I'm going to go
through just a little bit more in detail
to show you how that's done within a
Mars
so what you're seeing now in the lower
left hand corner is how with an amorous
we'd have creation wizards and so we
really try and take the user of them are
through this process step by step to
make it as easy as possible for you to
the first step as I said is to identify
all of the objects within your image and
what I'm showing on the right-hand side
is in is a mast cell from a plant cell
where we're seeing that very tips of
microtubules labeled with the protein
eb-3 that's been fused to a GFP and
you're seeing that those tips have been
have been identified based on the
parameters on the left hand side and
each of those tips is has has been
overlaid with a spot by a monitor so
after we've done that the next step is
to go in and track those over time and
that you can see that within a Mars we
I've used the auto regressive motion
algorithm but you're also able to use a
variety of different tracking algorithms
it just depends on the type of the type
of position that your spots have is an
object half and you're able to put in in
different parameters as well
in addition one thing that I've done
here within this analysis is I placed
what we call a reference frame into the
center of the cell where the organizing
of the microtubules it's happening and
so then that allows for later within the
work to analyze just how far away each
of those spots what I've identified is
from that Center from that microtubule
organizing Center
then I'll go type seven
and reporting are available in Amara
once you've trapped your your objects
within your so then you're able to go in
and do different types of analysis and
reporting
you
I'm going to show you a video now and
this video is showing you how I've taken
a specific cell and focus just on that
mask it out so I could focus just on it
again the ev3 spots at the end of the
microtubules have been identified you're
seeing those color-coded by how far away
they are from that reference frames that
I've put right on top of the microtubule
organizing Center so the colors are
matching the color bar that you see in
the bottom right hand corner and you're
also seeing the tracks over time
associated with in on than just just the
last few time points it's what you're
seeing and so these animations can be
made within a Mars and are a great way
of showing new results and reporting
those to others
another way of reporting the results and
showed that to others is of course to
represent the numbers and to actually
use the numbers so with NMR's
we do give you many many different
measurements as I mentioned before
there's a variety of measurements that
we will be report those are found within
the software it can also be exported out
into Excel for you to work with outside
of a month if you choose to
another option for reporting your
measurement with NMR's is to use our
vantage view and so what you're seeing
here is a plot where I'm looking at
displacement over time for each for each
of the spots for each of the tracks
and you can see cuz it's growing over
time as you expect but any of the
measurements that we make you can also
put within a plot like this so you could
be looking at shape differences over
time you could go get intensity changes
over time it could also help you find
this interaction that I was speaking up
before when you're looking at the
intensity of another channel over time
and you can see when two objects are
touching one another so it does give you
the vantage view it gives you a nice
quick way of seeing the the results of
your of your analysis within a Mars
without having to take it to another
software
today I have shown you how you can use
Amara to analyze the intracellular
dynamics whether they be in two zones
and looking at about sorting looking at
vesicle movement or objects that are
that are found at the tips of
microtubules or even telomeres within
that within the nucleus all of those
things are possible within a Mars and
you go through the different steps of
the Mars with in our creation was there
too then finally analyze and report
those report those measurements I would
also like to mention before I leave
everyone data Mart the Mars team has
released a new Amar's viewer this is a
free software that you can find at a
Morris comm slash viewer and it allows
you to look at your raw data file and so
that could be the files coming off of
the dragonfly microscope or from a
variety of other microscope
manufacturers as well as the Amar's
files that you have analyzed already and
this can be this can be placed on any
computer that has the recommended
specifications you can find that
information also a timorous coms flash
viewer and this is great to make sure
that you can share your data with with
anyone as long as they have fewer as
well so we hope that just helps everyone
spread their work to others and now what
I want to do is open open it up to
questions from everyone there's a chat
box or a question answer box that you
can type your questions into they don't
have to course not Joe questions for me
but also questions for dr. Yoshioka and
then we'll be able to answer those for
you so thank you everyone for your
attention and I appreciate your time
okay just before we go through the
questions Meredith I just want to go
through the dragonfly which is the
system that dr. Yoshioka used to do to
get his wonderful data that he just
presented so dragonfly is under
multimodal confocal imaging system it is
a high contrast multimodal platform and
why is it a multimodal platform it is a
multi-modal platform because it allows
you to do confocal imaging and it is an
instant comfo call it also allows you
other imaging modalities such as laser
wild field imaging turf and even super
resolution with this storm or surf
stream you can use a dragonfly with a
very broad range of wavelengths from the
visible to the near-infrared and it has
a very flat illumination across the
whole field of view because we use
indoors patent borealis illumination
system
so because it is a multi-point confocal
you can see it immediately in the
imaging here on the top it has very fast
image acquisition when compared to point
scanning confocal the faster acquisition
will obviously increase your temporal
resolution also dragonfly is a dual
spinning disk land system and therefore
it will allow you higher efficiency in
the capture of life it is therefore less
photo toxic and combined it with the F
CMOS and the MCC DS ultra sensitive
detectors you will be able to capture
more photons and will cause less photo
toxicity and less photo bleaching to
your samples leading to less simple
damage and better life better and longer
live imaging
I'll just want to talk briefly about the
South Stream which is a technique that
as you just seen doctor Yoshioka used a
lot in his research and this is a an
image from a movie get dr. Yoshioka just
presented with first stream third stream
will yells an increasing resolution when
compared with the diffraction limit of
light between two to six times more and
the low power requirements used for
first stream make it compatible with
live cell imaging so Enders starts to
algorithms allow you to acquire images
that break the diffraction limit of
light at the frame rate as fast as ten
frames per second
so the dragonfly comes in two models the
dragonfly 500 the full complete solution
and the more compact solution offered
either as an inverted microscope or a
net right microscope the dragonfly 200
there is much more to talk to you about
the dragonfly but due to time
constraints I will now stop for
questions I'll be happy to take any
questions on the system and I'm sure
that dr. Yoshioka and Meredith are also
very happy to take questions about the
science and how to analyze your data we
are very thank you for you attending to
our webinars and I hand it over to you
Christy
Thank You Claudia and Thank You Meredith
and dr. Yoshioka for informative
presentations we will now start the live
Q&A portion of our webinar if you have a
question you would like to ask please do
so now just click on that ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen and we will answer as many
questions as we have time for okay let's
get started
our first question is dr. Yoshioka let's
begin with you
what is your next challenge in pi3
kinase a study okay so that's a good
question
soon actually we planning to was in
beyond the in vitro study so today I
skipped many data about in vivo knockout
my study so actually we have many
knockout mice of psi K kinase sheets
alpha beta and also and the counter
partner against PSV K in hospitals
now we are planning to study in vitro
look at my study to show that in unison
and function significance of pursue TSU
K in vivo and also in vitro study we are
now planning to show the fret imaging by
undal dragonfly substring microscope so
we already published several paper about
in the summer signaling press study but
I want to try to again to show more high
resolution and distribution of activate
site in the end zones so that's our my
you know the next challenge
that's okay it is thank you now Claudia
let's come over to you this question is
coming for you is a possible fuse photo
manipulation tools with the dragonfly
thank you very much for your question
yes it is possible and we at under also
supply photo manipulation tool we supply
move light and micro point just briefly
micro point allows single point
illumination and you can use it for high
laser power applications such as
ablation and DNA damage and multi
it's a device more suitable for
approaching active it's extremely fast
and allows simultaneous multi-point
illumination of very complex region
Sadia thank you yes and don't reopen
this next one is for you do you know why
pi3k c2 beta was shown to be required
for the action at clathrin-coated
structures
yes that was a good point so we already
find intersexual key prayer to read it
fits better lip movement to the doctrine
arches and crossing court structure so
but we still in not enough data about
the relationship between the section 1
and C 2 beta so we will start to study
about more precise mechanism of [ __ ] to
beta regulation on intersection 1 so
maybe we have to test the possibility
that multi-protein Larkin silly cdc42
power regulate those complex formation
and regulate action formalization so
that key mechanism to understand for for
story of rustling me deep in the
psychosis thank you
he'll thank you dr. Yoshioka okay
Claudia and back to you again can you
combine surf with turf using the
dragonfly
yes you can and in fact you can combine
surf with any imaging modality in the
dragonfly white shield come focal or
tough water
earthers sorry being the fact that surf
will allow you when combined with a
confocal super resolution deep inside
your sample on the confocal mode or
increase your search resolution up to 50
nanometers in X Y F edge of the cell
membrane at the cell membrane surface so
cells can be combined with any imaging
modality and will increase your
resolution thank you
you Claudia now dr. Yoshioka while we're
talking about sir why was imaging with
SERP important to obtain your result
basil actually we have suffered from
load the resolution and low sensitivity
of our conventional organ microscopy so
new to Dragonfire helped us with those
ich all issues so when we try to
determine the subcellular localization
of our interest within yourself during
fry allows us to perform march color no
a blue green LED and for that four
colors and also 3d imaging with
continuously high resolution confer wide
mode very wide view mode and also super
resolution sub stream mode in the same
sample i can say that if VG's absolutely
amazing and I was impressed with Drago
price of stream imaging that can provide
us with perfect balance of resolution
and speed thank you that's all
you know Claudia what is the maximum
speed that you can acquire with the
dragonfly
with the dragonfly as I just said before
it's a multimodal imaging platform so
you have different speeds considering
the different imaging modalities that
you are using so if you use it in the
control mode you can go as fast as 400
frames per second if you want to go even
faster you can use the wild shoot mode
and then you can acquire up to 1600
frames per second thank you
thank you now we're almost at a time so
let's hop to this final question and dr.
Yoshi okay let's have you answer this
one what are the main challenges that
you need to overcome to do your imaging
yes so we already have you know
dragonfly then now we can perfectly
examine the localization of the our
interest but now we are for planning
trooper home threat image to see the the
activation site of many signaling
molecules I already said like low lags
lab activation by using ground flies a
stream super resolution microscopy so
the goal of our project we have to
identify physical significance or or
cross the pH DK ice holes to understand
the entire pH DK family so thank you
very much
thank you dr. Yoshioka now before we go
I would like to thank our audience for
joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by the speakers
via the email address you provided at
the time of registration
I'd also like to thank dr. Kazuki yoga
dr. Claudia floor endo and meredith
price for their time today and for their
important research we'd also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor and/or
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand and
labret swill alert you via email when it
is available for replay we encourage you
to share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and we thank you for
joining us have a great day